whatever happens are your favorite foods
from childhood you got your dunkaroos
WWE bars hi-c ecto coolers essentially
our entire childhood has been
discontinued do you miss those iconic
foods from childhood that you just can't
seem to track down well we need to fix
that I'm Brenda I'm falling
they're tasty producers that miss our
childhoods and we're on a mission to
track down these forgotten recipes
recreate them from scratch and bring it
back now y'all so let's explore the
discontinued mine was the Nestle Wonder
ball you know what that's something that
today's kids would just never know I
think that we should try to figure out
what happened to the Wonder ball and
then see if we can get our hands on one
and make one you get on the computer
I'll get on the phone let's do this
[Music]
hello candy police mm-hmm this is he
what
okay Brenda you came out as the magic
ball it chocolate sphere with a toy
inside of it but there was an FDA rule
that said you can't combine candy with
toys this is why we cannot have nice
things
essentially it got discontinued and then
it was brought back check this out
since I they was freaking candy no
longer toys I remember when I was a
young girl trying to what would happen
if we tried to get one here from another
country oh forget it
that's illegal you know how much you're
gonna be fine with $2,500 flawed right
there says it right there okay so this
is a deal we can no longer have
chocolate with toys right so guess what
man
we're gonna have to me we're gonna have
to make it let's do it
okay how are we gonna do it what makes
up the ball it's like George's chocolate
toy that's it that's it
the more you know wait what kind of
chocolate are we gonna use this we're
gonna need someone who's super familiar
with that tape Oh Betsy oh you guys have
got to be kidding just like my childhood
in every shape or form so cool so this
is a tablecloth I feel so defenseless
we know you're a wonder ball 90's
enthusiast we want you to pick the
chocolate that most closely resembles
that of the childhood favorite I'm ready
for this y'all screen okay oh yeah
that's good no one's good all right girl
keep selfie number two okay that's okay
now chocolate number three oh yeah no no
hands down the first one when I think of
like the Nestle wonder of all I think of
milk chocolate right and this is
definitely a milk chocolate I believe in
100 probably men you guys yeah I mean
you have to do this from me but counting
on you to bring back literally an edible
piece of my childhood all right okay
that's enough get out of here
get out of here we got a job to do wait
can I take one of these no no she took
our sketch all right I've got these
that's really good
let's get going shall we we want this to
be as easy as possible so literally just
chips in the bowl microwave stir pour
microwave is away I'll be right back all
right I'm gonna just whip this guy in
here stir it around a little bit so I
think for this one we should do the
Alvin magic chocolate ball
I don't really know how to do that but
we'll figure it out so we've got this
guy yeah
alright so close them let's do this and
go around alright okay okay I think
we're pretty good
I think it's freezing time okay okay we
can stuff it with the toy I think what
I'm gonna do is just take a little bit
of chocolate and I'm just gonna cry
swirl it around that is it mama
thick with three C's and spaces in
between the scenes
I'm gonna go freeze these so I'm gonna
try to get these out I don't know if
it's gonna work it's still a little too
thin around the edges there so we're
gonna have to work pretty quickly this
looks like alien
I think that we're gonna have to
reinforce like around here I think it's
fine
I'm gonna go freeze these we're gonna do
another layer after that it's not super
pretty on the inside this is like the
thick double reinforced ones I mean oh
[Music]
[Music]
my god I cracked it a little bit but
that's perfect
it's bill okay it's perfect I want it to
be even perfect er let's put a toy in
there that's amazing
I think what we need to do to seal it is
melt kind of each half give me a toy
very quickly okay how do you close it oh
but I feel like this side needs to be a
little bit melty too okay okay I like
this I think we can make it even more
magical than this it's fine it's not
amazing right now it's just gonna think
it was my kindergarten work this one
looks like it's gonna come out yeah so
go about it maybe use some extra
chocolate to sort of like a village
let's go in with the glue and see what
happens but I honestly think pieces in
there boy toy we're doing forget the
damn talk oh that's a cute one that's
heavy okay Brenda I think she's
beautiful
Brenda
[Music]
fancy needs to see this I want her to
open it all right Brenda who's the least
clumsy out of both of us I just tripped
so that's me yes all right
ladies first this is if I drop this my
life is beautiful
I'm gonna see what surprises hide inside
you yeah wait I like this is so cool I'm
just gonna crack it open I think of
chocolate dinosaur eggs all yours this
is like better than the Nestle
Wonderfalls that I had as a kid oh good
I'm here best friend ever
wha I think our work here is done I
think so
[Music]